[Musique]
voici la nouvelle norme pour des
centaines de milliers d'Ukrainiens et le
Nouvel An échappe pas à cette dure
réalité des familles déchirées par la
guerre alors que quantité de leurs
proches sont mobilisées au lait le mari
d'Alina a été appelé en mars le
réveillon se fera sans lui
[Musique]
dans l'ambiance on s'envoie des textos
tous les jours et on s'appelle de temps
en temps
des appels que les enfants viate aux
arts et solomiya attendent toujours avec
impatience
tout simplement donc quand je lui parle
je suis heureuse et je suis fier de lui
mais c'est retrouvailles pourtant rares
ne sont pas toujours joyeuses Alina a
revu son mari au lait pour la dernière
fois en octobre lors des funérailles de
son beau-frère le parrain de leur fils
était déterminé à les combattre et ses
porter volontaires à cinq reprises avant
que l'armée ne l'affecte à une unité de
défense anti-aérienne
il a été blessé et n'a pas survécu il
n'est pas mort immédiatement on l'a
envoyé à cramatorks et il est mort en
chemin
il est mort pour que nous puissions
célébrer ce nouvel an et pour que nous
nous puissions continuer à vivre en 2023
continuer à vivre mais pour beaucoup
avec un sentiment de solitude que même
les embrassadent les plus chaleureuses
ne suffisent pas à faire oublier
Alina et ses jeunes enfants tentent de
s'accrocher à leurs rêves le retour de
leur mari et de leur père au lait
alors que la guerre ne montre aucun
signe d'affaiblissement au crépuscule de